originally a terminator was sent back in
time to wipe out humanity and now
Terminator Genisys has been sent a 2015
to show us that it worked there's
actually no more humanity left in
Terminator movies Terminator Genisys
with a Weiss Weiss Janice Weiss so
Terminator Genisys exists as hopefully a
reboot and revitalization to the
Terminator franchise judging by my intro
you know it's kind of not and it started
out really cool it shows the future and
it shows the story unfold as we know it
and then Kyle Reese has it get sent back
in time to save Sarah Connor and the
timelines completely different now and I
was loving that [ __ ] I was like okay as
long as we stick here it's gonna be good
then it takes a dip into another
direction not really the John Connor as
a terminator thing I mean that's
actually a thing that I was fine with
it's a terminator fan you would think
I'd be like nah [ __ ] this movie they
ruin John Connor when they do it I was
fine with it so now we have a new
Terminator trying to screw mankind who
happens to be John Connor and if you're
seeing that as a flaw that's like the
ninth thing wrong with the movie
seriously right what I like about the
movie is the gimmick that Arnold is back
as the Terminator that's what I really
like he was great as the machine we grew
up to love and the fact that Jai
Courtney is in this movie means that
Arnold is not the biggest robot in the
movie
seriously I have no idea I'm watching
the movie and I'm just going why was Jai
Courtney cast as Kyle Reese there's a
Jai Courtney would have been a fine
terminator in the movie he would have
been a great t800 he's a big dude he's
kind of stoic he has no emotion
whatsoever no personality he kind of
reminded me of Luke Skywalker from the
first Star Wars movie he was kind of a
whiner [ __ ] didn't own the entire time
he cracked jokes with no comedic timing
whatsoever he had zero chemistry with
Daenerys Targaryen who plays Sarah
Connor in this movie I was skeptical
about her I actually ended up liking her
as young Sarah Connor she was actually
enjoyable as a young chick who was just
ultimately raised to be a child soldier
to really look at John Connor from t2
that's what he was as kind of what Sarah
Connor wasn't this one it was really
neat seeing Sarah Connor in John Connor
shoes and in fact the movie just tries
to be too big and it is big but it can't
carry the weight of the load it's
toppling in on itself if it just stuck
to the fact that it's Terminator one but
it's a new timeline they're doing things
differently now that would have been
fine but then it goes another direction
with another direction is that JK
Simmons is in this movie I like the
concept of JK Simmons character but his
character was wasted and he was wasted
so you're like why
why even do that I imagine when making
this movie they were trying to pitch a
movie that was the next Terminator 2 and
in reality they have a movie that really
reminded me a lot of Terminator 3
seriously and I'm not just saying that
there are a lot of plot elements in this
movie that reminded me of Terminator 3
in the beginning you think there unright
and they do only to rewrite it the same
but kind of different but ultimately
like hey here's your new T 3 guys in the
end Terminator Genisys had some
enjoyment in it for me I had neat action
ish things nothing really memorable
you're not going to walk out going I
loved that one action sequence it starts
off and it looks like it's going in a
good direction and then it ultimately
just tries to be too big for its own
good so big in fact I think they cut
back on the special effects budget
because some of the t800 in the feature
don't look that great and t1000 looks no
better than he did in Terminator 2 it's
24 years ago folks it's a long time it's
entertaining ish but in the end you're
gonna walk out of Terminator Genisys and
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
one day yes I do for guides it's gone
now they're even plot elements in this
movie like Arnold Schwarzenegger who
sent him back no one really knows Laura
says it was John Connor but the movie
never set he never shows that happen
it's just like Kyle Reese go back okay
now there's an I don't think the writers
knew there was like I don't know people
aren't gonna think about this [ __ ]
people do man lock down your plot a bit
better people aren't as dumb as you
think they are there's a terminator
genisys have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more